MALE SPEAKER: Get ready for
the incredible hypnotist
Richard Barker live on stage.
Originating from
the United Kingdom,
he has hypnotized thousands of
people from all over the world,
from the Cayman Islands and
Bermuda to London and Las
Vegas.
He is considered one of
Europe's number one hypnotists
and is moments away from
dazzling and intriguing
you with the mystifying
phenomenon called hypnosis.
Richard Barker has been featured
on television and radio, as
well as magazines,
and has also published
a book explaining the
secrets of the stage you're
about to witness right now.
Ladies and gentlemen,
sit back and relax,
and be taken on a journey
of mesmerizing hypnosis.
Laugh harder than
ever before, and be
amazed beyond your
wildest imagination.
This is a once in a
lifetime opportunity
where you can be in
the show, giving you
the best seat in the house,
or watch it from the audience.
Either way, the
journey is ready.
Please put your hands
together and welcome
the incredible hypnotist
Richard Barker.
RICHARD BARKER: All right
ladies and gentlemen,
how are you all doing?
Good to see each and
every one of you.
My name is Richard Barker,
the Incredible Hypnotist.
Now how many of you
guys seen a hypnosis
show before, or actually
experienced hypnosis?
A few of you guys?
How many of you guys have
been hypnotized before?
OK.
See, I would argue each
and every one of you
probably have been hypnotized.
Maybe you just
don't know it yet.
Hypnosis is a phenomenon
that actually is just as
unique as the air you breathe.
It's all around us.
Now as a professional
hypnotist, I travel pretty much
across the country and in fact
the world hypnotizing people.
And my biggest
hurdle is actually
getting people the sense that
hypnosis is actually real.
So how many of you
guys-- you won't
hurt my feeling--
how many of you
guys think hypnosis
might be fake?
Couple of you guys.
See, I've been faking this
about 20 years successfully
and I've been
getting away with it.
In fact nobody's caught me yet.
Of course hypnosis is real.
In my day job, I help people
for weight loss, stop smoking,
removing fears and phobias.
I help athletes
improve their game,
whether it's golf,
tennis, basketball.
And when I work on
the cruise ships,
I turn ordinary people
into extraordinary people
through using the
power of the mind.
Now all hypnosis is-- there's
a whole ton of definitions
out there.
But honestly, the
best definition
I can give you for
what hypnosis is it's
a heightened sense
of suggestibility.
In other words, when you see an
advert or you see a billboard,
you have a normal
level of suggestion.
You go oh, that's pretty cool.
I might check that out.
Under hypnosis though, you
have a heightened sense
of suggestibility.
It's not a case of saying well
I might just check that out.
You have a natural
desire and an impulse
to buy whatever it is on that
billboard through hypnosis.
That's why they use
hypnosis in infomercials.
Now what we're
going to do today is
we're going to debunk some
of the myths of hypnosis.
We're going to
demonstrate it right here
with a few volunteers.
I know there's a few
of you eager and very
keen to get up on here.
And we'll get you up on
stage in just a few moments.
And when I do so, I'll
be using your imagination
to give the presentation.
So just before I do so, some
of the misconceptions for
hypnosis.
Now sometimes people
think you just
have to be flat out
dumber than a box of rocks
to be hypnotized.
How many of you guys
might think that?
One or two of you.
But in fact the
opposite is true.
It's been proven that those that
make the best hypnotic subjects
actually have an above
average level of intelligence.
Stands to reason.
I'm going to be asking you to
focus, relax, and concentrate.
Listen to the sound of my
voice and my voice only.
Shut off all other suggestions
coming into your brain
and just listen to mine
for about 45 minutes.
Which believe it or
not is very tough to do
if you're the kind of person
that can't concentrate for more
than two or three minutes.
It's difficult.
So you could have above
average level of intelligence.
Some people think that
when I hypnotise them,
I just go out of my way to
make them look flat out stupid.
I don't do that.
Some of you guys
don't need my help.
And those that do--
and I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding.
I don't go out of my way to make
you look stupid or embarrass
you or ridicule you in any way.
But when I do demonstrate
the power of the mind,
you will feel a level of
hypnosis or relaxation
that you've probably
never experienced
before in your
life, I promise you,
unless of course
you've been hypnotized.
Now one hour of hypnosis
feels like four to six hours
of uninterrupted sleep.
I know some of you
guys in this room
probably want a good
power nap right now,
and this is the place to come.
I promise you that.
Now, also I want to let you
know that you won't do anything
that you don't want to do.
There is a critical factor in
your brain that protects you
from any suggestions that I give
you that go against the grain.
For example, if I all of a
sudden get you sat in the chair
and tell you to
wet your pants, you
won't wet your
pants because there
will be a moral
protector in your brain.
You will only follow natural
decisions and suggestions
that I give you that
you can comply to.
So some people ask me,
can I hypnotize you
against your will?
Can I sneak up behind you and
just zap you into hypnosis?
If I could do that,
I wouldn't be here,
I'd be hanging around the
banks, extracting PIN numbers
all day long.
But it doesn't work like that.
So I can't hypnotize you unless
you actually really and truly
want to be hypnotized.
So you must will it
and want it to happen.
And when you do
become hypnotized,
normally there is an 80-20 rule.
80% can and will be hypnotized.
20% for whatever
reason just means
they were not focused, relaxed,
or concentrated on what I said.
So we're going to
have some fun here.
We are going to
have a good time.
I'm going to get some
volunteers up on here.
But like I said before, we are
looking for above average level
of intelligence.
And I know you
guys are very smart
and that's why you're here.
But let me just
test it real quick.
Everybody put your hand up
like this, do me a favor.
Just put your hand up like this.
Make a perfect circle like this,
just a perfect circle with all
the tops of your fingers.
Look at my circle.
Look at your circle.
Good.
Make a gun.
Make a perfect circle with
the tops of your fingers.
Make the peace sign to
make a perfect circle.
Look right at my circle.
Look at yours, and just place
it right there on your chin.
That's right, it's here sir.
Your chin is down there.
Oh my word.
It's just a level of
suggestibility, that's all.
That's not hypnosis
or anything like that.
But it just demonstrates
people do follow suggestions
uncritically thinking.
Now what hypnosis is,
just very quickly, there
are two parts to the brain.
There's the conscious mind
and the subconscious mind.
What I get into is
the subconscious mind,
and that's where a lot
of creative juices flow.
It's where you operate.
It's where your DNA is.
It's where your habits,
behaviors, beliefs are.
Your conscious
mind is just simply
what am I going to
have for dinner,
what time am I
going to leave work,
and what am I going
to do tomorrow.
That's critical short term
memory decision making.
But the subconscious mind
accepts truth as behavior
if I give you a
direct suggestion
to believe it to be true.
In other words, if I say my
jacket is green, under hypnosis
you will see a green jacket.
In other words, in
the subconscious mind,
you're programmed,
just like the computer,
to react to certain trigger
words that I would give you.
And the best explanation I can
give you is the conscious mind
just simply opens
and closes programs.
It's a mouse click.
It's a mouse click here.
It's a mouse click there.
And then you open
and close programs.
But hypnosis, in operating
in the subconscious mind,
actually records every single
keystroke you make since
inception of the build of the
computer until pretty much
it's crushed, which is why law
enforcement immediately take
the computer away and start
analyzing the hard drive
for all the keystrokes that
you just cannot get rid of.
And the subconscious
mind operates exactly
in the same way.
It records everything you
do in life from birth,
some would argue
even beforehand.
And it records
everything you do,
almost like a camera is just
completely on all the time.
Which means in your naught to
seven years, whatever typically
happened in that impressionable
part of your life
carries through into adult life.
Now what hypnosis can
do, it can actually
intervene if you have a nasty
habit or behavior that you
picked up along the way
along life's journey,
it can actually erase
it and scrub the scene.
It can also add
something to the scene.
So if you want to
improve performance,
it can add that to the scene.
so that's kind of
quickly what hypnosis is.
There was another demonstration.
I just want you to look
at the screens real quick.
Look at either
side of the screen.
You'll see in a few
moments a hypnotic spiral.
And I want you to look at
that screen in a second.
And when you focus
on the spiral,
I just want you to
stare completely
in the center of the spiral.
We'll just get Foster
up and running.
And then when you do look
at that, what you'll find
is you'll find a
laser focus effect.
We got it?
So what hypnosis-- here we go.
So what hypnosis does, it
gives you a guided level
of concentration.
So for example if you
ever tried to stream
two movies at the same time,
normally your bandwidth
can't take it.
Well the mind is the same way.
If you try and stream multiple
information into the brain,
eventually all the streaming
and all the multiple monitors
or the multiple
approaches fail, which
is why hypnosis is used
for laser targeted focus.
If you focus on just one
object in particular,
your mind will accept it
and perform far better than
if you tried to multitask.
So what I want you to do
is stare at the center
of the spiral.
And the more you stare,
the more tired you become.
The more tired you become,
the more in fact you stare.
As you stare at that spiral,
at some point soon when you
begin to see a tunnel effect,
I'll count from one up to five.
Keep staring at the spiral.
When I do ask you to
stare at the spiral,
just look at the
center of the bullseye.
I'll count up from
one up to five.
And focus.
Don't look around,
fidget, or fuss.
Just stare at the spiral.
One, feeling relaxed.
Two, looking at the spiral.
Three, looking at the
bullseye drifting in and out
of your mind.
Four, the deeper you
go, the better you feel.
The better you feel,
the deeper you go.
And in a few
moments but not yet,
you'll look away from
the monitor, but not yet.
Now when you look
away from the monitor,
stare straight at my face.
Five, stare at my face.
Yeah.
Sometimes you'll see
the swirling effect that
translates and actually
moves from one item
or one object
directly to the other.
Which is no different to how
you guys operate at work.
Sometimes you take that
baggage to that situation
or that problem to
another problem.
And what the mind actually
is better off doing
is putting them into
compartments, dealing with them
and moving them out.
So in your professional
lives, what we teach through
hypnosis is the power
of self-hypnosis.
All hypnosis actually
is self-hypnosis
with a level of
guided meditation,
but with suggestions.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to demonstrate hypnosis
right here, right now.
And I'm going to be asking
for some volunteers.
And when I do so, just
a couple of things.
Please come up here without any
injuries, illnesses, ailments,
or complaints that
you can blame on me.
Please do not come
up here if you
want to test hypnosis and
battle of the hypnotist,
because you will
win and I will lose.
I just don't have time
to really convince you
that you want to be hypnotized.
In other words, you must want to
be hypnotized to be hypnotized.
So if we do have some
willing volunteers that
would like to feel the
effects of hypnosis,
then let's have you up on
stage and occupy a seat
right here, right now.
We want a full nine seats,
every one of you filled.
Come on up.
Give a round of
applause as they come up
and volunteer to be hypnotized.
Can turn away the
spiral there Foster.
All right, good.
We've got nine people.
If we can get nine people,
the more the merrier.
Come on up if you
want to be hypnotized.
Good, good, keep coming up.
Perfect.
Couple more chairs,
maybe a couple more guys.
If you're thinking about it
and feeling it, come on up.
Come on up.
All right, we've got one
more seat, one more seat.
Come on.
All right, we've got it.
Brilliant.
Excellent.
Give me a round of applause
ladies and gentlemen.
They're going to be sharing
their personalities with you.
All right.
Now I'm assuming each
and every one of you
have not been hypnotized before.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD BARKER: Oh wonderful.
So you know you're more
likely to be hypnotized again.
It's probably
about 80% actually.
So you're going to drop
like a rock probably first.
Makes my job easy cause
I've got one already.
That's good.
All right, perfect.
Anybody else?
All right, so just
do me a favor.
I'll give you a demonstration
of what hypnosis feels like.
Put your feet firmly
flat on the floor.
Put your hands
uncrossed on your laps.
Uncross it, that's right.
And just listen to
each and every word
I say from this point forward.
I want you to just
look straight ahead.
I'll count to three.
When I count to three, just
simply close your eyes.
One, two, three.
Close your eyes.
Open them back up.
That's what hypnosis feels like.
There's no lotion,
potion, magic pixie dust.
Harry Potter's not going to
run on stage with a magic wand
and zap you into hypnosis.
See, sometimes ladies
and gentlemen people
are expecting to feel
a sense of hypnosis.
And there really isn't any.
All it is are your
eyes are closed
and you listen to each
and every suggestion
I give you, which is what
you guys can do yourself.
You know that little voice
in your head giving you
that little sort of self talk?
That self talk can be positive
or it can be negative.
Depends on what
that little voice
is saying to you at this
particular moment in time.
Now what we're
going to do is we're
going to shut that little--
whoa, you're already there,
aren't you?
Soon as you get that upturned
wrist, that means yeah.
Do you meditate?
You do, don't you?
All right, awesome,
you're number two,
is going to drop
like a rock as well.
Now you know as well as I do
that what the mind believes,
the mind achieves, right?
So if I set up and frame
this the right way, what
I'm actually doing is I'm
giving them embedded commands,
embedded suggestion.
In fact it's just
like embedded code.
I'm coding them right now
to fall into hypnosis,
and I haven't even done it yet.
It's just an embedded
suggestion that you guys
will be wonderful, each
and every one of you,
if you can focus,
relax, and concentrate.
And you're quite tired,
aren't you, right now?
We're going to get
you a good power nap.
It's what's going to happen.
Now there are just
a couple of rules.
Please do not leave the stage
unless I ask you to do so.
If I ask you to leave the
stage, I'll whisper in your ear,
leave the stage.
Now without any worries,
troubles, or fusses,
just stand up and make your
way back into your seat.
It doesn't mean
I don't love you,
it just means I can't
use you for the show.
Maybe you weren't at the
right level of hypnosis
that I can use you for, OK?
But don't leave of
your own free will.
So here's what happens
ladies and gentlemen.
Some people don't know whether
they're hypnotized or not.
And all of a sudden they stand
up, they leave the stage,
and all of a sudden they really
and truly were hypnotized
and they go and do something
really outrageous outside
and blame it on me afterwards.
So I've already told you,
don't leave the stage unless I
ask you to do so anybody.
Anybody out in the audience that
feels the effects of hypnosis--
there will be a few of you
as you tune into my voice,
you'll start to feel getting
hypnotized in your seat,
actually during this little
bit of a presentation here.
If you do feel that effects,
the person sitting next to you,
do me a favor and take pictures
of them as fast as you can.
But don't let them
fall out of their chair
and bang their head.
They'll have a massive
headache afterwards.
But if I do see them
hypnotized in the audience,
I might ask them if they want
to be a part of the show.
Or I'll certainly
wake you up and have
you enjoy the rest of the show.
Because this really and truly
is the best seat in the house
that you guys have
now just occupied,
because you'll have a
heightened sense of relaxation.
But also you'll
have a heightened
sense of listening to each and
every suggestion I give you.
Nod your head if you understand.
Perfect.
All right, so just in a few
moments, just some final rules.
Please block out all
the sounds around you
out as if they no longer
exist and just listen
to the sound of my voice.
Fully relax and just
listen to my voice
and allow yourself to go.
I know some people in this
room are rather analytical.
So sometimes if I ask
you to relax and float
on a soft fluffy
cloud of relaxation,
don't analyze how thick the
cloud is or how long it is
or how big it is.
Just assume that you can float
on a soft fluffy cloud, OK?
Because sometimes that is a
sticking point with people
and they'll ask me
afterwards, they'll
say, man, that cloud had a
little bit of gray in it.
I don't know, but
just go with it, OK?
Sounds good?
And I won't embarrass you
to do anything silly here.
We're just here to
feel the effects
and the phenomenon of hypnosis
and how it can apply to you
and your lives moving forward.
Sounds cool?
All right, so just put your
feet firmly flat on the floor.
Put your hand
uncrossed on your laps.
Just begin to relax as
you listen to my voice.
Just get a bit more volume on
that, Foster, just this track.
That's wonderful.
Now just for the
hypnotised volunteers
as you relax peacefully,
resting each and every day,
I just want you to listen to the
sound of my voice and my voice
only.
Now understand something, you
can't get stuck in hypnosis.
If you don't hear the sound
of my voice for five minutes
or more, you will naturally
emerge from hypnosis.
In other words, if I fall
off the stage, bang my head,
get a concussion,
go to the hospital,
after five minutes you'll
wonder where on earth I am.
But at least you won't be stuck
here or trapped all afternoon.
Now each and every one
of you can and will
be hypnotized if you just
want to be hypnotized.
Let it go and just relax.
So the hypnotised
volunteers, I want
you to stare at the ceiling.
You'll see some bright lights.
And as you stare
at the ceiling, I
want you to find a fixed
object or a fixed light.
Now just begin to
stare at the light.
Now in a few moments, I want you
to realize the more you stare,
the more tired you become.
The more tired you become,
the more you stare.
You guys in the audience
can find a fixed object
somewhere in the room as
well and just stare at it.
And the more you stare,
the more tired you become.
Now I'll be using the
word sleep quite a lot.
You won't actually
be sleeping though,
but it's just the word we use.
You will be relaxed.
Now in a few
moments as you focus
in on the light,
the more you breathe
and the more you hear my voice,
the more you will simply relax.
Now I'll count to three.
But not before, keep
staring at the light.
When I do count to three, we'll
just regulate and teach you
how to breathe and relax.
In a second when
I count to three,
we'll take a deep breath
in and out with me,
and you'll push all the
aches and pains, the worries
and the troubles
of the world away.
Allow yourself to sink
and drift and relax
and melt into a
level of relaxation.
One, two, three.
Take a deep breath in.
And breathe out.
That's good.
And just relax, each
and every way feeling
wonderful about yourself.
Now in a second I'll count
to three, but not before.
Keep staring at
your chosen object.
I'll count to three.
Simply take a deep breath
in and out with me.
Every time you breathe
in and breathe out,
you'll feel the
sense of relaxation.
One, two, three.
Breathe in.
Good, breathe out.
Push all the aches and
pains, worries away.
What happened today
is just another day.
What happens tomorrow
is a distant dream away.
What happened yesterday just
went into the memory vault.
Now in a few moments I'll ask
to take another deep breath in.
This time when I ask
you to breathe in,
you'll simply breathe
in and close your eyes.
And when you breathe out,
you'll allow your heavy head
to rest down to your chest.
Once again, I'll count to three.
You'll take a deep breath in.
When you breathe in,
allow your eyes to close.
And when you breathe out,
allow your heavy head
to rest down to your chest.
Now don't worry whether
I'm standing to the front,
to the back, to the left,
or to the right of you.
Just listen to my voice.
One, two, three.
Breathe in.
Close your eyes and breathe out.
Just feel the aches and pains,
worries and troubles disappear.
And allow your heavy head just
to rest down to your chest.
Now from this point
forward, the deeper you go,
the better you feel.
The better you
feel, the deeper you
go, keeping yourself fully
relaxed at all times.
Now in a few
moments, but not yet,
as you feel a sense
of relaxation,
as you listen to my
voice, allow all thought
processes to disappear and
just tune into my voice.
Now in a few moments
I'll count to three.
But not before, when
I do reach three,
you'll just simply
open your eyes.
You'll look at the object you
were looking at moments ago.
And as soon as you find
it, your eyes will close
and you'll sink down
further and deeper
into a sense of relaxation.
Because the deeper you
go, the better you feel.
In a few moments,
I'll count to three.
You'll simply open your eyes.
You'll look at
your chosen object.
And as soon as you find
it, your eyes will close.
You'll sink down further
and deeper into relaxation.
Every time you open and close
your eyes, think of sleep.
One, two, three.
Open your eyes.
Look at the object.
Close your eyes even further
and deeper, all the way down.
Keep your eyes closed.
Now you'll keep your
eyes closed at all times
unless I ask you to open.
Keep them completely closed.
In a few moments, but not
yet, I'll count to three,
but not before.
When I've reached three,
you'll simply open your eyes.
You'll look at the
objects and you
find that your eyes will close.
Every time you open and close
your eyes, think of sleep.
One, two, three.
Open your eyes and close
them all the way down.
Allow your heavy head just
to rest down to your chest,
keeping your eyes
closed at all times.
Nothing will trouble,
worry, or disturb you.
In any way, allow
yourself to relax.
Now in a few seconds I'll
count to three one more time.
This time when I reach three,
you'll simply open your eyes.
You'll look at the object.
As soon as you find it,
your eyes will close.
You'll sink down
further and deeper
into a level of relaxation.
One, two, three.
Open your eyes and close them.
All the way down, just
allow your heavy head
to rest down to your chest.
Push all the aches and pains,
worries and troubles away.
You feel wonderful
about yourself.
The abilities to
be able to relax
are so profound
and so unique, you
will never lose this experience
for the rest of your lives.
Now in a few
seconds but not yet,
I want you to focus
on the soft muscle
tissue surrounding your eyes,
also known as your eyelids.
But I want you to imagine
your eyes are becoming heavier
and heavier and heavier.
In fact in a few
moments but not yet,
I want you to imagine it's
almost as if superglue has
been poured across your eyes.
I want you to imagine your eyes
becoming so heavy, so lazy,
and so tight that
as you focus in
on your muscles of
your eyes, imagine
your eyes becoming heavier
and heavier and heavier.
Imagination is way more
powerful than knowledge
or anything else.
Imagine it's almost as if
your eyes are so heavy,
so shut tight, so tired-- in
a few moments but not yet,
when I ask you to try
and open your eyes,
you won't be able to.
In fact, it's almost
as if superglue has
been poured across your eyes.
In a few seconds but not yet,
I want you to try and open
your eyes, but not before.
Now you'll realize the more
you try and open your eyes,
the more you fail.
The more you fail,
the more you try.
But you'll realize
in a few seconds,
but not yet, when I ask you
to try and open your eyes,
you'll understand the more
you try and open them,
the more you fail.
And the more you fail,
the more you try.
But either way you will not
be able to open your eyes.
It's almost as if
superglue has been
poured across your eyelids.
Now you will lend me the
use of your imagination.
Now one or two of you
might be able to peek
and open up your
eyes at this stage,
but that's not why you're here.
Just listen to the suggestions.
In a few moments when I ask
you to try to open your eyes,
you won't be able to.
They're stuck down to your face.
Try and open your
eyes, but you can't.
Stop trying.
Relax and just think of sleep.
Each day in every way feeling
better about yourself.
You're all doing
wonderful up on stage.
Now in a few
seconds but not yet,
as you feel the sense
of relaxation drifting
from the top of your head all
the way down through the tips
of your toes, no
power on earth can
stop you drifting into a
level of deeper relaxation.
Because the deeper you
go, the better you feel.
Now in a few moments but not
yet, I'll count to three.
But not before, when
I do reach three,
I want you to imagine as
if every single muscle
tissue in your arms,
legs, face, and feet
just simply disappear
and collapse.
In fact, I want
you to imagine it's
almost as if you're made from a
handful of loose rubber bands.
When I reach three
but not before, I
want you to imagine
every muscle tissue,
every fiber of your body
simply turns to jelly
and completely and
utterly relaxes.
Any tension, any aches, or
any pains will just disappear.
You'll feel yourself
loose and limp just
like a child's soft toy,
just like a wet dishrag.
In fact on three, you'll
find every muscle tissue
in your body simply dissolves
and collapses, loose and limp
like a rag doll.
You'll feel yourself slumping
forward in your chair.
That's perfectly normal.
You have imaginary seat belts
keeping you safe at all times.
But you will allow every
single muscle tissue
to simply dissolve and
collapse, almost like a handful
of loose rubber bands.
One, two, and three.
Just collapse and each and every
muscle tissue in your arms,
legs, face, and feet, allow
them to collapse, keeping
your eyes closed at all times.
Now in a few moments, I'll be
coming up and down the line.
I'll be touching you on
your left or right wrist.
I will in fact just raise
your hand a couple of inches
off your lap.
The moment you feel
me touching your hand
and raising it a few inches off
your lap, the minute your hand
touches back down
on your lap, it
will immediately send you
deeper and more relaxed.
And the deeper you go,
the better you feel.
Allow all the muscles
to simply dissolve
as I pick up your
left or right wrist
and just plop it back
down on your lap.
Just allow yourself to relax.
There you go.
And the deeper you go, right
there, the better you feel.
Just relaxing each and
every day and every way,
feeling great about
yourself, relaxing deeper,
further, deeper you go.
And as you feel me touching your
left or right wrist, the minute
your hand touches
back down on your lap,
it sends you further and deeper
into a level of relaxation.
That's good.
And the deeper you go,
the better you feel.
Now in a few moments, I
want you to understand.
You'll listen to each
and every word I say.
And every word I
say becomes truth.
And truth becomes
your ultimate reality.
You will in fact keep your
eyes closed at all times.
Unless I ask you
to open your eyes,
you'll keep them
completely closed.
Now from this point forward
I want you to understand,
if ever you hear the
audience give you
a massive round of applause,
no matter whether your eyes are
open or your eyes are
closed, if you ever
hear the audience give you
a massive round of applause,
no matter whether your
eyes are open or closed,
as soon as you
hear that applause,
you realize it will
help you relax.
It will send you
further and deeper
into a level of relaxation.
Every time you hear a large
noise clapping, cheering,
it will just help you relax and
send you further and deeper.
Now I want you to
understand you'll
hear the audience give you
a massive round of applause
in a few moments.
The more applause you
hear, the better you feel.
And the better you
feel, the deeper you go.
Now ladies and gentlemen
in the audience,
I'll count to three,
but not before.
When I do reach
three, I would like
you to give as much
noise out as you possibly
can on the understanding
that the more noise you make,
the better they feel.
The better they feel,
the deeper they go.
And the deeper they go, the
better the presentation.
So I'll count to three, and
help your friends and colleagues
relax.
Get ready guys.
One, two, three.
Give it all up for the
volunteers, as loud as you can.
[APPLAUSE]
Keeping your eyes
closed at all times.
And the deeper you go,
the better you feel.
And the better you
feel, the deeper you go.
That's good guys.
All right, we got it.
Now just for the
hypnotised volunteers,
just some final words of advice.
Now ladies and gentlemen,
this is a slightly bit
of a numbers game.
Like I said before, 80% can
and will go into hypnosis.
But there's always about 20%
that won't for whatever reason.
So what I do is I
like to cut the pack.
I like to look at
who I'm going to keep
and who I'm going to release
back into the audience.
So what I'm simply
doing is looking
for those that have a level
of deeper relaxation, those
that can focus, relax,
and concentrate the most.
And the way I do
it is just simply
by a power of elimination.
So in a few moments
but not yet, I'll
count to three but not before.
When I do reach three,
your eyes will be open.
You'll be sitting
upright in your chair
when I do reach three.
I want you to realize
that if you ever
hear me say the word
sleep, no matter
whether your eyes are open
or closed, if you do ever
hear me say the word sleep, no
matter whether your eyes are
open or closed, as soon as you
hear me say the word sleep,
your eyes will
immediately close.
You'll sink down in your
chair just like a rag doll.
Now understand if you ever
hear me say the word sleep,
your eyes will
immediately close.
You'll sink down in your
chair just like a rag doll.
So ladies and gentlemen,
I'd like to introduce myself
to the volunteers.
I like my volunteers to have a
chance to introduce themselves
to you guys.
When I count to three, you'll
be fully alert, wide awake.
One, two, and three.
[CLAP]
Eyes open, welcome back guys.
Awesome, good to see you.
You guys know how
to rest and relax.
That is beautiful.
What did you say
your name was again?
AUDIENCE: Charity.
RICHARD BARKER:
Charity, you feel good
and relaxed don't you?
Charity, Richard,
nice to meet you.
Sleep Charity.
Sleep.
Just close your eyes and relax.
That's it.
And the deeper you go,
the better you feel.
Keep your eyes closed,
relaxing peacefully, resting,
drifting at all times.
What was your name?
AUDIENCE: Cappy.
RICHARD BARKER: Gabby?
RICHARD BARKER: Cabby?
AUDIENCE: Cappy.
RICHARD BARKER: Cappy.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RICHARD BARKER: Wonderful.
I got you.
Nice.
Sleep.
Just relax.
Close your eyes
and rest and relax.
And the deeper you go,
the better you feel.
And the better you
feel, the deeper
you go, keeping yourself
relaxed at all times.
I know you were good too.
How are you man?
AUDIENCE: I'm very good.
RICHARD BARKER: And
what was your name?
AUDIENCE: Ravi.
RICHARD BARKER: Ravi.
Nice to see you my friend.
Sleep.
Just relax.
Close your eyes.
And the deeper you go,
the better you feel.
Nothing will trouble, worry,
or disturb you in any way.
Sinking, relaxing, focus in.
And what was your name again?
AUDIENCE: Jenny.
RICHARD BARKER: Jenny.
Nice to see you as well.
Just sleep Jenny.
Just close your eyes.
Just relax.
And the deeper you go, the
better you feel, resting.
How you doing sir?
AUDIENCE: Good.
RICHARD BARKER: What
was your name again?
AUDIENCE: Jay.
RICHARD BARKER: Jay,
nice to see you man.
Sleep Jay, just relax.
Just let it go.
And the deeper you go,
the better you feel.
Keep your eyes closed at all
times, resting, relaxing.
I'm just going to have you go
back in the audience for me one
second.
Take a seat back
in the audience.
How are you doing man?
AUDIENCE: Good.
RICHARD BARKER:
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Sayeesh.
RICHARD BARKER: Sayeesh,
nice to see you man.
Sleep Sayeesh.
Sleep.
Just relax.
I'm going to have you go
back into the audience
for me Sayeesh.
There you go, nice
and carefully.
That's good.
How you doing?
AUDIENCE: Good.
RICHARD BARKER: Awesome.
What was your name?
AUDIENCE: Laura.
RICHARD BARKER: Laura.
Would you mind just stepping
into the audience for me?
Thank you so much.
And what was your
name my friend?
AUDIENCE: Akshay.
Akshay.
RICHARD BARKER: Akshay.
Well nice to see you my friend.
Sleep.
Just relax.
Let it go.
And the deeper you go,
the better you feel.
And the better you
feel, the deeper you go.
Give them on more
round of applause
would you ladies and gentlemen.
They're going to be sharing
their personalities with you.
Relaxing all the way.
Is anybody in the audience
feeling the effects?
Was there anybody with
their eyes closed?
Anybody I need to know about?
Anybody laying on the floor?
No, we're good?
All right, perfect.
Now this is for the volunteers.
You'll listen to each
and every word I say.
Every word I say becomes truth.
And truth becomes reality.
I'm just going to
rearrange you real quick.
On the kind of three,
your eyes will be open.
You'll be fully
alert and wide awake.
One, two, and three.
Welcome back everybody.
Would you mind just coming and
taking a seat in there for me?
That would be perfect.
And can you just come on
the end, come this way.
And I'm just going to have
you come and sit right here.
Perfect.
You guys know how to relax.
I just want you to look
at hands real fast.
Look at the hands.
Look at the hand.
Look up at the hand.
And sleep.
Just relax.
Every muscle tissue, every
fiber in your body just
relaxing all the way, relaxing.
Now just for the
hypnotized volunteers,
you'll listen to each
and every word I say.
Every word I say
will become truth.
Just relax my friend and
truth will become reality.
You will literally listen
to every word I say,
and you'll feel
good about yourself.
Just relax.
Now in a few
seconds but not yet,
I want you to realize
something profound
and unique about yourself.
In a few seconds
but not yet, I want
you to understand something.
You're all small
goldfish getting
ready to swim around in a
beautiful small goldfish bowl.
Now you can use your
hands, legs, face, and feet
to take a swim around the bowl.
I want you to realize the more
you swim, the better you feel.
And the better you
feel, the more you swim.
Now in a few moments but not
yet, your eyes will be closed.
You'll be sitting
upright in your chair
and you'll be swimming on three.
In a few seconds you'll be a
small goldfish swimming around
in a small goldfish bowl.
And you'll be feeling
wonderful about yourself
with your eyes closed,
getting ready to swim.
On the count of three, using
your arms, using your legs,
using your face and feet to
take a wonderful swim, on three.
One, two, three.
You're swimming.
Use your hands.
Use your face.
Close your eyes.
Swim, swim.
And the more you swim,
the better you feel.
Swim, swim.
Use your hands,
legs, face, and feet.
Keep swimming, swimming
in the goldfish bowl.
The more you swim,
the better you feel.
And the better you
feel, the more you swim.
Keep swimming in
the goldfish bowl.
Swim, swim, swim, swim
in the goldfish bowl.
Just take a swim.
Freeze.
Hang on.
There's a shark in the bowl.
Freeze.
There's a shark.
It's looking right at you.
Make yourself look smaller.
Shrink.
Shrink down.
There's a shark.
Shrink.
It's gone.
Swimming.
Use your hands,
legs, face, and feet.
Swimming, swimming,
swimming, swimming happily
in the goldfish bowl.
And the more you swim,
the better you feel.
And the better you
feel, the more you swim.
Now if anything touches
you on the top of the head,
it's goldfish food.
You want to eat the food.
If anything does touch you on
the top of the head, it's food.
You're going to want
to eat the food.
Right there, eat the food.
Go ahead and get that food.
That's lovely.
Go ahead and eat that food.
Eat the food.
Right there, that's it.
The more you eat,
the better you feel.
Eat the food right
in the goldfish bowl.
That's good.
Eat that food right there.
The more you eat the
food, the better you feel.
Get that food.
Eat the food.
That's right.
And sleep.
Just relax and sleep.
Every muscle tissue
in your fiber
just relaxing itself and
drifting further and deeper.
And the deeper you go,
the better you feel.
Now for the
hypnotized volunteers,
I want to understand something
very profound and very unique.
In a few seconds, I
want you to realize
you're all at the beach.
We're getting ready to
have a thoroughly good time
at the beach, and I
want you to understand,
you're going to have a lovely
ice cream, a Mister Softee, Mr.
Whippy, Mr. McFluffy.
Now you'll get that ice
cream in a second on three,
and you'll lick that
ice cream as fast
as you can before it melts.
It is actually about
95 degrees outside.
It is roasting hot.
I'll be giving you
that ice cream.
You'll sit upright
with your eyes closed,
and you'll lick the
ice cream as fast
as you can before it melts.
One, two, three.
Get the ice cream.
[REPEATS "LICK IT"]
Its dribbling.
Lick it.
It's dribbling.
It's on your wrist.
Lick it.
It's dripping all the
way on your wrist.
Lick it.
It's on your elbow.
Suck your elbow.
Lick it.
It's on your elbow.
It's on your knees.
It's dribbling on your knees,
on your knees, on your knees,
on your knee.
Lick it.
It's on your knee.
And sleep.
Just relax and sleep.
And the deeper you go,
the better you feel.
You ready to have some fun guys?
You guys ready?
In a state of stunned
silence, I love it.
All right, good.
You guys can make noise.
It's fine.
They're concentrated.
They're good.
All right, who's a colleague
of this young man here?
Anybody?
Nobody?
All right, now this is just for
the person I'm touching now.
I want you to understand
from this point forward,
I want you to realize
your new name is EIEIO.
Always was and always will
be and always should be.
Nod your head if you understand.
In fact, if ever I ask you a
name from this point forward,
your name was and
always will be EIEIO.
Nod your head if you understand.
Good, feeling good
about yourself.
Excellent.
Now just for the person
I'm touching now,
I want you to realize
you are really and truly
the original Tinkerbell.
Now in a second I want you
to understand if you ever
hear me say the
word hypnosis, just
for the person I'm touching
now, if you do actually ever
hear me say the word
hypnosis, you're
going to realize that wings
are sprouting out of your back,
in your back ready to fly.
You might take a hop,
might take a flutter,
but you might just fly with
those wings on your back there.
Nod your head if you understand.
Good.
You'll realize if ever
I say the word hypnosis.
Now just for the person
I'm touching now--
or you're good man, I got you.
You just relax.
There you go.
Just for the person
I'm touching now,
I want you to realize if you
do ever hear me say my name,
Richard Barker, I want you
to realize and understand
you're completely and
utterly in love with me.
If you do actually ever
hear me say my name,
Richard Barker,
you'll immediately
stand up and shout as loud as
you can, I love Richard Barker.
As soon as you do so, you've
forgotten you've done it.
Nod your head if you understand.
If you do actually ever hear
me say my name Richard Barker,
you'll immediately stand up and
shout, I love Richard Barker.
Nod your head if you understand.
Good.
Now just for the person
I'm touching now,
I want you to realize something
profound about yourself.
You're going to realize your
name has completely and utterly
vanished.
I want you to understand the
more you try and remember
your name, the more it's gone.
The more you try and
remember your name,
the more your name
has disappeared.
I'll be asking you your name.
It's completely vanished
from your memory banks.
Nod your head if you understand.
The more you try and remember
your name, the more it fails.
You can't remember it at all.
I'll give you a top tip though.
If you do actually sing
happy birthday to yourself,
your name just might come back.
Nod your head if you understand.
Good.
So I'm just going
to rearrange them
real fast ladies and
gentlemen, just find out
who we've got up on here.
On three, one , two, and three.
Eyes open, welcome back.
Good to see each and
every one of you.
What did you say your
name was my friend?
AUDIENCE: EIEIO.
RICHARD BARKER: All
right, that's cool.
And what was your name dude?
AUDIENCE: Akshay.
RICHARD BARKER: Akshay?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Akshay.
RICHARD BARKER: Akshay.
Oh, that's lovely.
Nice to see you.
Welcome to the hypnosis show.
It's good to see each
every one of you.
That's perfect.
And what was your name?
Cappy.
AUDIENCE: Cappy.
RICHARD BARKER: Cappy.
I got you.
I'm Richard Barker.
Nice to see your sweetheart.
AUDIENCE: Nice to see you.
I love Richard Barker.
RICHARD BARKER: Oh, OK.
That's fine.
Thanks.
You can let go now.
Yeah, that's take.
Take a seat.
What was your name again?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I don't know.
RICHARD BARKER: Just your
name is what I'm after.
AUDIENCE: I don't
know what my name is.
I don't know what it is.
RICHARD BARKER: All right,
I'll come back to you.
What was your name bro?
AUDIENCE: EIEIO.
RICHARD BARKER:
Oh, come up here.
Just stand up here a second.
Why don't you come over there.
I want you to think
hard about that,
because you had one
when you came in here,
just to let you know.
When I say check it downstairs,
I don't know if they do that.
But come this was man.
Oh, you're tall.
Is that your first name?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RICHARD BARKER: So EIEIO
is your first name.
AUDIENCE: Correct.
RICHARD BARKER:
What's your last name?
AUDIENCE: Gupta.
RICHARD BARKER: Do you
have a middle name?
AUDIENCE: I don't.
RICHARD BARKER: So
it's EIEIO Gupta.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RICHARD BARKER: Can you
spell that for me dude?
AUDIENCE: E-I-E-I, and
then O, and then G.
RICHARD BARKER: All right, good.
Give him a round of applause.
He was awesome.
Take a seat there man.
I've got you.
I'm Richard Barker by the way.
Sorry, nice to meet you.
Yeah, it's cool.
AUDIENCE: I love Richard Barker.
RICHARD BARKER: It's a
friendly place, isn't it?
Just go ahead, take a seat.
That's awesome.
Could we get your name again?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I don't know it.
RICHARD BARKER: Do me a favor,
just stand up a second would
you?
Could you stand up
for me a second?
Does anybody know this
young lady in the room?
You do?
What's her name brother?
AUDIENCE: Charity.
RICHARD BARKER: Charity?
Guess what?
Your name's Charity.
It's gone.
Oh actually-- oh stand up.
I got you.
So Charity, your
name is Charity.
But think about it,
and it's disappeared
out your memory banks.
What's your name again?
It's for $100, if you
can give me your name.
AUDIENCE: I don't
know what my name is.
RICHARD BARKER: I will
give you-- it's Charity.
That's a top tip.
I'll give you $200 if you can
give me your name, Charity,
which of course it's vanished.
What is that?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
RICHARD BARKER: Try singing
"Happy Birthday" to yourself,
see what happens.
Sing out loud.
AUDIENCE: I don't
want to sing out loud.
RICHARD BARKER: What?
AUDIENCE: I don't
want to sing out loud.
RICHARD BARKER: OK, just
sing it to yourself.
Let me know when
your name comes back.
AUDIENCE: Charity.
RICHARD BARKER: It's Charity?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RICHARD BARKER: Give a round
of applause, it's Charity.
That's awesome.
Charity, that's fantastic.
You know what?
It's gone.
Whoa, I got you.
Sorry, what was it, your name?
Oh never mind, take a seat.
That's good.
Give a round of applause
ladies and gentlemen
would you to the
stars of the show.
Now one thing interesting
about hypnosis
is you can actually create
a memory that lasts forever,
or remove a memory,
i.e. your name
or a number or
something like that.
So what this is
really useful for is
that if you have something
in your background
or in your DNA that was
an unpleasant experience,
like some kind of trauma
perhaps or a situation
that you really would like
to forget-- of course as we
mentioned, it's in
the subconscious mind
and will stay there
forever because it's almost
like a computer hard drive.
You can't scrub it.
But through hypnosis,
I can scrub the scene.
I can create the
effect of the scene
actually being altered or
being removed completely,
like a name just like that.
Now the more you try
and remember that name,
the more it disappears.
But I will give it back to
you at the end of the day.
What did you say
your name was again?
AUDIENCE: EIEIO.
RICHARD BARKER: OK man.
I could make that
last indefinitely.
But can you imagine being
stopped by the police outside
and your name's become EIEIO.
All right, just listen to
each and every word I say.
On the count of three, sleep.
Just relax.
Every muscle tissue,
every fiber in your body
just relaxes and Rests.
And the deeper you go,
the better you feel.
And the better you
feel, the deeper you go.
Now just for the
hypnotized volunteers,
I want you to understand
something very unique and very
interesting about yourselves.
In a second but not yet,
I want you to understand
you're all exotic animals.
And by exotic animal, I don't
mean pig, sheep, cat, goat.
I don't ordinarily
mean something
you find at home or on a farm.
Now by exotic animal,
I mean something
you might find on
safari or in the zoo,
something you might find
on the Discovery Channel
or a place far, far, far away.
Now in a few
moments but not yet,
you'll embed in your
subconscious mind
the animal of your choice.
You'll do all the actions,
do all the motions,
do all the movements.
You will truly become the
animal of your choice.
Now in a few seconds
but not, you'll hop.
You'll fly.
You'll crawl.
You'll slither.
You'll do whatever it is
that your animal does.
You'll leave your seat and
have a prowl, have a crawl,
have a fly, or have a hop.
Now embed into your
subconscious mind
the exotic animal
you've just become.
And in a few seconds
your eyes will open.
You'll adopt the position,
the stance, the posture
of that exotic animal.
One, two, three.
Animals, take shape.
[MUSIC - THE TOKENS, "THE LION
SLEEPS TONIGHT"]
Take a posture.
Take a fly.
Take a crawl or whatever
it is your animal does.
Take a fly.
Come off of chairs.
Take a hop.
Take a crawl, whatever it is.
Take a flurry.
Crawl around, you're fine.
Experiment with your
new animal of choice.
Take a hop.
Take a crawl.
Take a flight.
Take a flurry.
Take a walk around
the savanna there.
Take a crawl.
Take a hop.
Do whatever it is
your animal does.
That's beautiful.
Take a crop.
Take a hole.
Take a fly.
Take a crawl.
And freeze.
Just freeze.
Freeze right there.
Freeze.
Trying to find out what kind of
animals-- what kind of animal
are you?
AUDIENCE: A giraffe.
RICHARD BARKER: A giraffe, OK.
What kind of noise that make?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
RICHARD BARKER: What
kind of animal are you?
AUDIENCE: I'm a lion.
RICHARD BARKER: A lion, OK.
What noise does that make?
AUDIENCE: [GROWL].
RICHARD BARKER:
That's very good.
Interesting.
All right, what kind
of animal are you?
AUDIENCE: I was an elephant.
RICHARD BARKER: An elephant.
What noise that make?
AUDIENCE: [ELEPHANT WHINE].
RICHARD BARKER: I tell
you what, that was good.
That was great.
What kind of animal are you?
AUDIENCE: A snake.
RICHARD BARKER: A snake.
What noise does that make?
AUDIENCE: [HISS].
RICHARD BARKER: That's great.
Excellent.
Now just for exotic
animals, I want
you to realize something unique
about yourselves, animals,
something very interesting.
I want you to understand
that the favorite food
of your choice is embedded
in the hair of some
of the audience members.
Now in a few
moments but not yet,
I want you to realize as you
look out into the audience,
you'll find your favorite
food embedded in their hair.
And if you come across something
that doesn't have any hair,
you'll have a natural
impulse and a desire
to kiss them repeatedly
on the top of the head.
Whenever I say freeze,
you'll immediately
stop what you're doing.
One, two, three.
Animals, go ahead.
Go and find some food.
[MUSIC - THE TOKENS,
"THE LION SLEEPS TONIGHT"]
That's great.
Look, some of the
audience right there.
There's a little bit over there.
The more you eat,
the better you feel.
Go ahead as fast as you can.
Go get all that food.
And the more you get,
the better you feel.
And the better you
feel, the more you get.
Go ahead, take look.
Take a prowl.
Take a hop.
Take a flurry.
Take a crawl.
Go and get as much food
as you possibly can.
Go ahead and get that
food right there.
The more you eat,
the better you feel.
The better you
feel, that's good.
The more you eat-- the more you
eat, the better you feel free.
Freeze.
Just freeze.
In a second but not
yet, when I reach three,
you're no longer animals.
You're back to normal.
You fully know where you are
and everything's returned back.
Every faculty comes
back to normal.
You will in fact though wonder
what on earth you are doing.
One, two, and three.
Holly moly.
Charity, what are you doing?
Come back over here
and just take a seat.
Give them a big round of
applause ladies and gentlemen
real quick.
Come over here real fast.
Take a seat.
Real quick, take a seat.
All right, just take a
seat right here my friend.
Take a seat.
That's, guys, that's lovely food
you had right there by the way.
It's great.
Take a seat-- there you
go-- wherever you want to.
Take a seat wherever
you want to.
Take a seat.
Look at the hand real quick.
And sleep.
Just relax every muscle tissue,
every fiber in your body.
Now I'm going to bring
you from one up to five.
When I do bring
up one up to five,
I want you to understand that
one hour of hypnosis or less
felt like four to six hours
of uninterrupted sleep.
In fact, when your eyes
open and you go back
to work or go back
into the audience,
you'll feel wonderful
about yourself.
In fact, you'll feel better
than you've ever felt before.
You'll feel vibrant,
alert, and alive.
And all the applause
will in fact be for you.
One, feeling refresh,
feeling alert, feeling alive.
Two, feeling like you bathed
your eyes in a cool mountain
spring.
Three, feeling the energy
rushing into your veins.
Four, feeling better than
you've ever felt before.
And in a second but not
yet on five, eyes open.
Big stretch.
And give them a big
round of applause.
Ladies and gentlemen, five,
eyes open, fully alert.
[APPLAUSE]
You guys are great.
All right.
What was your name again?
AUDIENCE: Charity.
RICHARD BARKER: Charity, good.
Excellent.
What was your name my friend?
AUDIENCE: EIEIO.
RICHARD BARKER: OK,
we'll fix that later on.
Sort of changes all the
passwords there doesn't it?
Username, EIEIO.
All right, you guys
can make your way back
into the audience.
Give them one more round of
applause ladies and gentlemen,
the stars of the show.
These guys were awesome.
Awesome, awesome.
Now just before I go
ladies and gentlemen,
we have reserved about
10 minutes for questions.
There are microphones
either side of the room.
If you do have a question about
hypnosis or what you just saw,
please do feel free to get ready
and get behind the microphones
and ask me any questions
you want about hypnosis,
self-hypnosis, and
actually how it
can improve you both
personally and professionally.
I mean, hypnosis has been
around for a very long time.
And I'll tell you, if you
learn how to self-hypnotize,
you will absolutely feel
better about yourself.
If anybody actually
struggles with insomnia,
can't get a good
night's sleep, hypnosis
is the best remedy for that too.
So if you do have any questions,
I'll be hanging around.
I'm quite willing to take some.
There are microphones
on either side.
All you have to do is
put the question there
into the microphone
and I'll answer it
fully and frankly
for you guys as you
get prepared to ask a question.
So we'll fire away.
Yes ma'am?
AUDIENCE: So what's an easy
way to do this for yourself?
RICHARD BARKER: Good question.
So for self-hypnosis-- so one
of the best ways I've found
is you know sometimes
that you feel
that anxiety level creeping
in, and things like that?
And what tends to
happen with anxiety
is what the mind believes,
the expectancy of the anxiety,
it actually creates it.
So it fulfills it.
The best way to
actually self-hypnotise
is take three breaths in.
First of all, focus
on a fixed object.
Could be a flickering flame.
Could be a television.
Could be something you
have at home, eye fixation.
Take three breaths in.
Just close your
eyes, which simulates
slowing down your heartbeat,
and just think of nothing.
Just don't think of anything.
Just think of nothing.
Just think of sleep
and relaxation.
And then what I like to do
is have embedded suggestions.
I'll have suggestions
that I give myself
which commonly are known
as the affirmations
or the embedded suggestions
I'll give myself.
And all I'll simply do is take
three breaths, close my eyes
and relax.
Open my eyes, read
an affirmation
or a positive suggestion,
close my eyes.
Take three breaths in.
I normally do that in
the morning because it
sets my day up correctly.
But basically just
closing your eyes,
taking three breaths in and
slowing down your heartbeat.
Sounds good?
Are you going to give it a try?
AUDIENCE: I will.
RICHARD BARKER: Excellent.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Why is there
a dragon on your jacket?
RICHARD BARKER: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Why is there
a dragon on your jacket?
RICHARD BARKER: Why is
there a dragon on my--
because it has hypnotic powers.
It didn't do it today,
but sometimes it
jumps off and actually zaps.
No, I just like a
dragon on the jacket.
I just like dragons on jackets.
AUDIENCE: Can hypnosis
help with relationships?
RICHARD BARKER: Absolutely, yes.
Hypnosis can help
with relationships.
And the thing is,
most of what we do
and how we do it as
humans, whether we're
interacting with family or the
person that is in our life,
whether it's marriage or
dating, whatever you think about
actually translates
into reality.
So whatever your
thought processes are,
your thought process translates
into an action, typically.
So what if you could change
that thought process around?
And for relationships
in particular,
it's about having that
change of thought process.
So how do you do it?
It's a little bit like
the answer to the question
beforehand.
You write it down,
first and foremost.
And then you give yourself
a sense of relaxation,
which you can do as a couple.
And then you give
yourself the affirmation
of the embedded command.
So absolutely works
for relationships.
I do actually get
a lot of couples
come to see me for sex and
health and relationship
building as well.
So I thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you indicated that
the success rate was about 80%
when you had people come up.
Today, here it was about 44%.
Why do you think that was?
RICHARD BARKER: Here, you've got
different levels of hypnosis.
You've got somnambulistic,
right there.
And you've got different
mild levels of hypnosis.
So I reckon there in about
a room of maybe nine, yeah,
probably about 50%.
But then I can do this again
tomorrow and it would be 100%.
I could do it again
the day after.
But overall, overarching,
it's roughly about 80%.
So when I work on
a cruise ship, I
know I'm going to
lose at least 20%.
AUDIENCE: So if it was
just normal variation.
It wasn't something about
the people or the atmosphere
you think?
RICHARD BARKER:
You know, I would
say it's a tough environment
to relax in front of all
your colleagues and your peers.
And what I find is
it's a higher rate
when you're on a cruise ship
and you don't know anybody else,
because you've got no fear of
letting yourself totally go.
But this room is
a little bit tough
because obviously you
work with each other
and you don't want
to be seen to be
letting yourself go too much.
So that's about normal.
Yeah, that's about right.
Hi.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi.
First, thank you.
It was great.
RICHARD BARKER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have maybe
a funny question.
Can you use hypnosis to
persuade your colleagues
to do what you want?
RICHARD BARKER: Absolutely.
Some of the best persuaders
and influencers are hypnotists.
Now I have a saying,
each day in every way,
I'm in the business
of persuasion.
And each day in every way
I'm getting better at it.
Now this is not something new.
When you were children and
you wanted to get something,
you did two things.
You either influenced,
manipulated,
or persuaded your
parents to have
what it is that you wanted,
or you threw a tantrum
and created a scene to
get what you wanted.
So it's nothing different
to what we do in adult life.
But if you anchor
some statements,
we have things called
arcing statements
and undeniable truths.
For example, an
undeniable truth would
be it's a beautiful
day outside isn't it?
You get somebody
in the yes state.
And the more you get them
in the yes state, when
you ask for the bigger
commitment, the more chance
you have for them to say yes.
So if I want to sell
something to somebody else--
and I have a book on selling
with hypnosis-- that I know
I have to get them into
an agreeable state.
So you can do that
in your workplace.
The way you would do it was,
it's a wonderful day outside,
isn't it?
And you would, agree wouldn't
you, that the sky is blue,
isn't it?
Well yeah.
It's just like the infomercials.
By now, you'll
realize the benefits
of my products and services.
And by now, you'll
pick up the phone
and dial 1-800-SIRMIXALOT,
because you
need to buy the Shamwow
or whatever it might be,
because by now you can see the
benefits in your life of it.
So of course the embedded
command is buy now,
and you're pointing right
there at the buy now button.
So yes, it can be used for
influencing and persuading
colleagues, absolutely.
I think we're this side.
AUDIENCE: Have
you ever used this
to influence and persuade
colleagues or something
outside of shows?
RICHARD BARKER: Yes.
I get asked if I use
this in my dating life.
And I demonstrated this
once in a restaurant.
I went on a date,
very fancy restaurant.
I didn't want to spring
for the high end food.
So I diverted the person's eye
to mac and cheese and a Diet
Coke.
And then I proceeded
to have a red wine.
I had a steak.
And I had a wonderful time.
And all the servers just
couldn't believe it.
So you can use it for
all kinds of benefit.
I use this in emails.
I use it on the phone.
I use it in dating.
I'm just in the habit of
using it all the time, yeah,
absolutely.
Once it becomes habit and
it becomes normal to you,
and like I said, my motto is I'm
in the business of persuasion.
Each day in every way
I'm getting better at it.
I'll test it on police officers.
I'll test it on
different circumstances.
And I always win.
Typically I always get the
result I'm looking for.
So thank you.
Good question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you think it would be
possible to build technology
to either assist or
even fully automate
the process of
hypnotizing someone?
RICHARD BARKER: I do.
I do.
We are using video streaming
and online platforms right now.
Some of my clients are in
California and I'm in Orlando.
And I'm using systems
and platforms right now
for that process.
One of the things I saw the
other day which was interesting
was a texting system
that navigates you
into the yes state.
Like a robotic you
say this, I say that.
If you say this, I say that
flowchart, an algorithm.
And getting somebody
into an agreeable state--
because the more somebody nods
their head, the more they're
going to comply, the
less resistant they are.
You're in the business of
implanting a suggestion.
You have more chance
of it to be successful.
I think it is going to get
somewhat automated or somehow
guided.
Like even if it's a talking
head graphic-- because you heard
some of my language
I used, a lot of it
was in the pattern of threes.
I set up the ready, set, go.
You can automate that.
In a few moments but not
yet, when I use that,
I'm actually setting up
anticipation and expectation,
because I know the mind
will follow through if it's
expecting to follow through.
So to answer your
question, I do think
that this can be automated.
Some clever programming
can get this automated.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I noticed throughout
the program that you
were speaking
virtually constantly,
using very few gaps.
Are you doing that to drown
out the internal voice,
or is that just your style?
RICHARD BARKER: Yes.
It's a little bit of
a pattern interrupt.
So I'm keeping them at
the level of my pattern
and interrupting their
normal thought process.
So I'm not giving him
a chance to think.
So the more I keep
talking, the mind
has to focus on that voice.
And therefore it can't think to
itself, what time is this over?
What time do I need to
get back into the office?
It just has to be following.
So it is a hypnotic language,
yes, the hypnotic nonstop,
verbalizing suggestions
and commands to give people
less chance of being resistant.
AUDIENCE: How did you spot which
participants were ready to be
hypnotized or were hypnotised
versus the ones that weren't?
RICHARD BARKER: When they
actually first came out--
AUDIENCE: When you asked
them to leave the stage.
Like how did you know?
RICHARD BARKER: You know,
it's a good question.
It just goes with gut,
to be honest with you.
I'm looking.
I'm looking at those that
are looking somewhere
around the room or
looking elsewhere.
I'm looking at those that
I believe are relaxed.
There's no direct science.
But when I touch somebody,
I can feel catalepsy.
I can feel arms loose and
limp or arms stiff and rigid.
Especially when
you touch the hand,
I can feel those resistant
and those less resistant.
And you can just tell,
when you look at somebody,
you just get that
sense, especially
if you've been doing this for a
while, that not here, not now.
Doesn't mean not ever, just
maybe not here, not now.
OK, we need to wrap up.
So I'll take the one more,
if they're really quick,
or just one more real fast.
And then we'll need
to close this off.
AUDIENCE: For the category
of the people who did not get
hypnotised, does
it mean this thing
doesn't help them any at all?
RICHARD BARKER: They still
got a level of relaxation.
But the question was-- can
you just repeat that please?
AUDIENCE: For the
category of people
who don't get hypnotized,
that 20% category
that you referring
to, does that mean you
or your activities
doesn't help them?
RICHARD BARKER: You
can come back tomorrow
and be hypnotized if you
don't get hypnotized today.
You can self-practice
hypnosis as well.
It never means never.
I've had people that just
could not be hypnotized,
like five times in a row,
and all of a sudden one
particular time they dropped.
It has something to do with
what you did when you woke up,
what you ate for lunch, what
you're thinking and feeling.
But all these guys will
get a sense of relaxation
just for being up here.
And actually if I were
to hypnotise them again,
like some of the
stronger ones, they
would fall into hypnosis
much faster and much quicker
the second time around.
Some of my clients they
walk into my office
and I just say sleep
and they're out,
and then I work on them
because they already
adjusted to what-- they're
already in the frame of mind.
OK, thank you.
Well we are right out of time.
I hope that was
interesting for you guys.
I hope it was somewhat different
and you had a good time.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
And I'll stick around outside
if you have any questions.
And again, it was nice to meet
each and every one of you.
And thanks for the volunteers
for taking part and taking
the plunge.
I appreciate it.
And thank you.
Enjoy the rest of
your afternoon.
Thank you very much.